le verrière de valérie lemercier
français et brésiliens y avait comme
dans tous les dvd y avait beaucoup de
choses en plus avant mais bien sûr il ya
il ya des tas de dessins des photos un
bêtisier une chanson enfin il ya des
bonus avait alors voilà il ya plein de
choses en plus ce qu'elle donne à votre
film c'est qu'en fait la vraie marginale
parce que ce qui est drôle c'est que la
vraie marginal cl quoi c'est le
personnage qui n'a pas sa place c'est
aussi un film sur les gens qui savent
pas où aller ou pas quelle est leur
place
c'est ce couple d'homosexuels qui sont
complètement dans l'establishment dans
la normalité et c'est elle qui débarque
de sa campagne qui en fait est l'intrus
oui ça c'est drôle oui c'est sympa aux
parents ils voulaient un garçon non
quand et maintenant ils voulaient ils
ont eu quatre filles du bon allez pas
les pauvres parce que c'est bien quand
même et non la campagne savamment
préparé garçons non ça va ça va mais
beit umar farouk attendait à voir un
garçon et donc quand vous êtes arrivé
c'était une fille bah oui bravo je crois
je crois dans les sentes vous appeler
mon petit val ou quoi eh oui on parle au
masculin quoi oui oui de très longtemps
mais ça a changé maintenant maple type
sans qu'ils aient un petit effort lie à
israël a pris donc j'avais fait ce film
pour vous montrez à vos parents que si
vous aviez un garçon sur le pas été
terrible oui aux parents c'était des
agriculteurs mais chic quand même non
oui si vous voulez vous vous étiez comme
les filles du patron il fallait fallait
pas la ramener parce qu'ils étaient des
fils du patron a beaucoup de gens du
village qui travaillait pour vos parents
d'où votre obsession ne pas déranger
d'ailleurs fallait quand même pas trop
large et il fallait faire profil bas
quoi oui et alors à 9 ans mais c'est ça
rigolait pas je suivais lemercier parce
qu'à neuf ans vous avez écrit un papier
à votre mère comme quoi vous maquille
auriez jamais coup je ne font pas que
j'ai sur le visage
là c'est impressionnant ses coups de
téléphone demain matin et c'est à dire
que je pensais que c'était mal le
maquillage et j'aimerais que le pape
bennis dépôt de fonds de teint même très
plaisir
après je me sentirai mieux dont vous
avez fait vous avez fait profil bas très
longtemps et qui un jour aider un petit
peu besoin de m'exprimer voyez vous oui
donc il a fallu que je m'exprime j'ai
commencé avant de faire les visiteurs
j'ai commencé par jouer un spectacle 400
fois et puis j'ai fait d'autres films
aussi avant et voilà c'est sûr ça un
gros succès donc
et malgré le succès que vous avez vous
êtes toujours un peu à côté c'est
toujours un peu différente mans ben je
sais pas différente de qui vous sentez
pas intégré me sentais toujours un peu
marginale non si c'est pas grave non moi
par exemple sur l'histoire de féministes
à quand il fait des histoires de
mannequin dans les vitrines
parce que il ya des choses mais qu'allez
vous étiez au mouvement de libération
des faits par exemple au nom oui c'est
une amie qui qui a fait ce mouvement je
trouve ça joli et ça me voilà ça me ça
me dérange pas on voit défiant en
maillot de bain dans les vitrines sa
[ __ ] non plus il ya des fixes ça vous
dérange vous mais moi je m'en fous un
peu franchement non mais je sais que ça
fait un scandale série ya toujours des
gens qui trouvent qu'il faut où il faut
des scandales pour tous alors que j'ai
des choses quand même plus importantes
dans la vie que ce savoir je pense que
si une fille est de gagner sa croûte en
étant là si ça lui va ça lui va ça va si
elle fait passer à 25 ans tant mieux
pour elle ce serait bien social et enfin
des peines nos jours qui ont plus de 50
ans ne pas passer rue bayard parce que
stéphane duhamel
à chaud c'est un peu gênant les filles
dans les maillots de bain des grands
magasins ah bon d'abord il n'ya pas le
prix ensuite ne sont pas vraies petites
d'être un peu marginal c'est pas du tout
au contraire moi c'est moi je trouve ça
bien simplement vous êtes vous aimiez
bien être seul vais pas trop sortir de
chez vous vous pouvez partir en week-end
pas les vacances pour moi les vacances
et être chez moi et mon rêve le rêve de
ma vie c'est de dormir tous les soirs
dans mon lit ouais je n'aime pas aller
dormir chez des gens comme donna pyjama
une brosse à dent donc je connais pas
c'est pour moi un cauchemar mais comme
ça t'oblige si des fois on se retrouva
en vacances les gens enfin bon pour moi
les vacances et c'est chez moi je n'aime
pas le soleil parce que je veux d'abord
je ne pense pas que normand bon week-end
ça ne m'intéresse pas ben voila mais
j'ai plein d'autres centres d'intérêts
bah oui voila j'ai d'ailleurs voilà et
puis les spectacles et puis écrire et
puis à fabre ce à quoi dites moi vous
savez vous êtes la cliente idéale pour
lentilles portrait chinois vous